[Musik]
wird sie miteinander vereint immer
zusammen unterwegs haben sie fast da
waren wir zur sternstunde jahr 2010 und
auch in dieser sendung werden die themen
als eigentliche dem jahr am meisten
beschäftigt habe wenn es ein aaaa
schlauderer und für seine ganz
persönlichen star stunden verzehr im
jahr das machen erhöht
im kosmostheater zürich bevor man das
möchte paar momente aus der union
[Musik]
neben wir wirklich das leben das ihr
leben wollen herzlich willkommen breslau
vielen dank herzlich willkommen ergo
danke in den letzten wochen neue damen
und herren wurde gestrickt was das zeug
hält um diese tussi herz zu produzieren
wir können nicht irgendwie rum schreiben
als würden wir gemütlich ist aber mal
1870 irgendwie auf dem sofa sitzen mit
vielen project ja ich finde wir wundern
uns eigentlich viel zu wenig über das
wunderwerk was wir sind in körper und
geist
wir verstehen unser universum bis eine
sekunde nach dem urknall
aber da stecken wir fest eine geschichte
kreieren heißt mannschaft ein universum
ich kann sie jetzt hier anfassen sie
sind mein dialogpartner sie sind
wirklich der welt als solche eine
gerechtigkeit aus der testieren dass das
vermag ich nicht ich sage freiheit ist
wichtiger als alles andere das alles um
den islam herum lässt mich nicht kalt
sondern das bewegt mich existenziell
ich will mich nicht in den himmel loben
ich habe eben auch diesen defekt und ich
kann einfach alles mal die schweiz als
unter gehendes römisches reich
das nehmen wir leider gottes als
schlusswort unseres brechen ganz ganz
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
nicht regeln hier studio dann machen wir
schluss
[Musik]
und ich nehme so schöne durch handel
kommt das bürgerfest und dass james key
für die gerne mal machte blumig
natürlich die jungs ja durch priester
schönste remo largo mit dem lebenswerks
passend erleben und die roja dass ich
ihn unbedingt einsatz vor einem jahr wo
man nur den kopf gott ich vor der 80
jährige ungarische philosophin agnes
heller der sich seit der sinn des lebens
ist es zu leben wenn sie auf ihr
bewegtes leben zurück schauen sehen sie
darin einen sinn zu ziehen was ist sinn
er sehen das leben selbst ist sind der
sinn des lebens ist zu leben
und natürlich habe ist ein hat mein
leben einen sinn von dem standpunkt aus
wo ich jetzt bin ausgesprochen immer
wieder müsse druck dann kann nämlich
gespräch mit dem jakob kern wofür du
nord nahrungsmittel abgab in syrien
koordiniert es bleibt eigentlich ganz
simpel und doch bitter nötig was
erwarten sie von menschen wie mir die
hier in sicheren im trockenen sitzen
ich glaube das wichtigste ist dass sie
nicht vergessen dass sie nicht vergessen
dass alle passiert ist dass das syrien
immer noch zerstört ist
das schulden wir den syrern dass wir sie
in unseren gedanken behalten und dass
wir mit leiden wenn bild wie die leute
in aleppo besonders berührt hat mich ein
muss sagt von deutscher philosoph gert
scobel wo sieht einige jahrzehnt
meditiert und da seid meditation ist wie
in vorbereitung auf sterbe oder
verteuert was sich ändert glaube ich ist
unsere
einstellung dazu wenn man wenn man die
erfahrung machen kann dass man bis jetzt
sehr bildhaft gesagt vorher schon weg
sein kann und dass dieses weg sein
können oder weg sein ein ganz normaler
zustand der wirklichkeit ist dann hat
man vielleicht vielleicht auch nicht
weniger angst mich bezahlt statt sprüche
der mir wahrscheinlich mit dem charles
foster geführt er hat glaubt ihnen das
wie ein fuchs wie einen hirsch und erwin
lotter wo bislang als otto ziemlich
unangenehm genug um am leben zu bleiben
müssen sie unmengen fressen für mich
würde das bedeuten einen bigmac alle
vier minuten kommen ja der überraschend
steht momentan völlig hat die witzigsten
momente erlebt mit dem pop philosoph
richard david precht und ganz zum
schluss vor das antik mal würmer und
grillgasse die unbesetzten stellen sich
überhaupt nichts das schmeckt noch gar
nichts
dort konnte ihm massen essen und auch
kein dschungelcamp den nägeln auf
sondern man stellt sich wirklich eklat
hatte davor ausnahme sagt das gefühl ich
esse ungesalzene schmecken ja nix mit
dem motto hier wird liebig red und haben
die lacher übersicht play3 de freesen
partner ag - spargel paket wie genau
soll ich meinen partner sehen wenn ich
ihn sehe wie man sparen gesehen hat was
ist die neue perspektive man betrachtete
spargeln die wir schon so oft gesehen
haben genauer und sah wie schön sie sind
und wer sein bild anschaut entdeckt
diese schönheit denn man hatte den
impuls genauer hinzusehen
warum ist letzte gespräche dem jahr habe
ich mit dem bergsteiger reinhold messner
dürfen für einen grenzgang zwischen
liebe und tod unterschied wenn man so
eine grenzerfahrung verstaut ist dass
wir wieder gebohrt ich gehe gegen den
selbsterhaltungstrieb das ist der
stärkste trieb den wir haben da hinauf
um nicht umzukommen und wenn es mir
gelingt nicht umzukommen ist das
anschließend wie eine wiedergeburt und
das ist vermutlich der hintergrund
warum mir das immer wieder tun dass da
eine art wiederholungszwang auftritt ich
sage nicht eine sucht da sind ja keine
opiate im spiel höchstens körpereigene
aber es hat einen wiederholungszwang in
sich weil dieses wiedergeboren sein
dieses gefühl wieder geboren zu sein
ein sehr starkes gefühl ist was ist das
für ein gefühl können sie das noch näher
beschreiben
ich habe das ganze leben vor mehr ich
habe das ganze ja wieder auszufüllen ich
kann mein leben mit neuen geräten
ausfüllen
ich habe es mir selber erobert joachim
zehnter 2 stunden die erste sternstunde
karl ist schön dass für das ist schon
schwierige situationen künstliche
situation er ist nervös weil ich
eigentlich vor fehlern abgesprochen was
man nicht sieht man hätte einen ohrwurm
das wetter betroffen hier das konzept
mit vorbereiteten fragen so dekorieren
wasser zu erlösen
was aber immer die nächste frage im kopf
hause kamera sowas licht blendet und das
ist für mich die große herausforderung
auch heute noch das ausblenden und focus
die routine geht schaut ja ja aber es
ist sicher dass sprach an dass meistens
zwei gäste ist mir bewusst
es ist einfach wer bis verschiedene ich
weiß nicht wie es bei der ich du bist
richtig nervös
nein nicht wirklich nicht was ich schon
immer noch so eine grundsätzliche
spannungen und aggressionen finden auch
so die spannung zwischen jedis
sternstunden stuttgart oder das radikale
tobago und irgendwo oder will es wissen
muss der gast bei laune halten die
stange halten
duschen ein sitzgefühl das obwohl ich
das endlich vertrauen dass ich wieder
versuchen ins und land zu bringen und
auf der anderen seite als förderer und
nicht alles daran dass der gast absolut
verdient so wohl fühlt in dem zwiespalt
in einer bis gut seine bringen
die spannung ist natürlich da die küste
zu und fotos
damit sendet und mit kraft und bananen
tut das sehr schön wieder eingeholt
was isst du dimanche rutschte am morgen
machen das heft aber bei deren dauert
bis ein neues angefangen das europäische
facebook gegangen und hätte sogar das
paar tipps abgeholt
vom social media experte robert bossmann
off screen ich habe ihn ja gesagt ich
bin neu auf facebook und ich wollte die
gelegenheit nutzen den professor für
digitale medien hier zu haben was soll
ich denn nun als erstes posten auf
meiner seite
sie haben gerade einen facebook account
eröffnen haben sie das profil schon
ausgefüllt das hat man schon gemacht das
ist ganz wichtig dann würde ich sagen
als erste meldung natürlich unbedingt im
sinne der selbstwerbung der üblich ist
auf facebook schreiben sie doch dass sie
gerade ein erhebendes gespräch über die
abgründe von facebook hatten
und vergessen sie nicht meinen namen mit
einzugeben und natürlich den link dann
zum video
damit jeder darauf klicken können ok
also eigenwerbung muss sein das habe ich
schon mal gelernt hätte mir ein bisschen
schwer aber machen wir jetzt so link
mache ich später dazu ist gepostet ich
bedanke mich sehr
ich bedanke mich auch für die davis
namens ja ja wir herrscht somit facebook
erwartet dass ich teil stylistin so
schön seit das auf die schätze der
ausdrucksmittel zuschauer und
zuschauerinnen extrem freue mich
wirklich über alles relativ große
feedback und übernommen
man ist gut die hippies oder tipps oder
fragen und auf der anderen seite ist hat
genauso wie florian tasten herzlichkeit
interessant relevante anzahl klicks und
das bisher elitären zwar den knicks
überholt und war son oder zu uns gott
für mich ganz klar auf kosten von rund
die klasse und das ist für mich immer
schwierig ist einfach sehr gut 70 und
unterstützen
am ende dass dort nicht nur über
facebook gerät sondern über
digitalisierung im generellen und ich
hatte dann world web forum in zürich mit
2 experte ist künstliche intelligenz
reiter und fragesteller maschine
eigentlichen kreativ sie und wendet ein
ganz besonderer gast kam jetzt kriegen
wir besuch von einem überraschungsgast
das ist papa ein humanoider roboter und
berlin bringt ihn zu uns möchte ich mal
hallo sagen was ich ihm die hand drückt
und vielleicht mal schauen
ja bist so künftig bis zur künstlichen
intelligenz ist noch etwas weit okay das
kann
kreativität ist eines der dinge
wovon man sagt dass maschinen das so
schnell nicht können dass wir menschen
das nach den maschinen voraus haben wie
lange dauert das denn ihrer meinung nach
bis maschinen kreativ sein können
aufmerksam ist erkennt hinweise auf das
was in den nächsten fünf bis zehn jahren
geschehen wird verpasst man diese
signale stutzt man das gilt auch im
hinblick auf die technologien wie bei
diesen roboter vor ein paar jahren gab
es einfachere roboter die sich
weiterentwickelt haben und entwickeln
werden
technologien also nicht anhand ihres
heutigen zustand sondern ihre
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten innerhalb
einer bestimmten bandbreite wie wir
müssen bereit sein uns anzupassen an
diese herausforderungen mit all ihren
vor und nachteilen
so sehen wir das wir haben ein
zeitfenster von fünf bis zehn jahren und
schritte zu unternehmen und zu reagieren
auch ohne zu wissen wohin genau die
reise geht
aber das ist in ordnung kat mode
leiterin nicht wirklich fest ob
kreativität der maschine vorbehalten ist
aber ein anderer gastronom kann nämlich
der jubel harari womit dem burghof
models 2010 aufgrund der herr der ganze
platz ihr team einig zum thema
kreativität und ich habe den studio im
musik vorgespielt wovon eine maschine
komponiert worden ist kennen sie diese
musik
[Musik]
ich kenne dieses bestimmte stück nicht
aber im buch beschreibe ich ein
computerprogramm das musik im stil von
johann sebastian bach komponiert und die
meisten menschen können wie auch ich den
unterschied zwischen seine musik und der
computer komposition nicht erkennen und
das computerprogramm kaum zu schreiben
sie 5000 choräle in einem tag
komponieren und wenn es um kunst geht
stellt sich einmal mehr eine
philosophische frage was ist die
wichtigste aufgabe der kunst
gewisse leute finden kunst solle vor
allem gefühle auslösen
doch wenn kunst emotionen wecken soll
werden computer sehr bald viel bessere
künstler sein als menschen
denn aufgrund ihrer datenmenge und
rechenleistung können sie viel besser
mit unseren emotionen spielen als jeder
menschliche künstler
sie verfügen nicht über eigene emotionen
computer haben kein bewusstsein sie
haben keine gefühle
aber sie haben die fähigkeit die
emotionen der menschen viel präziser zu
manipulieren oder zu inspirieren als
jeder menschliche künstler in zukunft
die programm so gut sind dass man eben
gehört und trotzdem glaube ich dass die
musik denen andere weltkriege der
einfach mehr wüsste dass von einer
maschine komponiert ist nämlich nicht so
schwierig glaubt das extrem starke
emotionen auslösen sowie das musik von
beethoven oder verbraucher macht aber
klar die kunst strom
bus zurück gefühl ausdrücken und event
der mensch wird verstanden wird also
wenn ich beethoven lasse dann wirklich
der schmerz spüren der vorstand werde
und wenn ich weiß dass der maschine
komponiert verliert das sind reits dass
man das musikstück
ich weiß dass ich wirklich sagen dass
ich ein guter unterschied wird also
gerade der maschine
wobei auch komponiert muss ich wirklich
sagen muss es sein aber ich bin generell
die ganze frau was eigentlich mit der
künstlerin theley ganze schon viel
darüber diskutiert wo das die letzten
vier punkte singularität dass irgendein
maschinen übernahme gerade wie der
mensch und so sehr dies topische vor
steinig achtung mit maschinen und alles
wird überrollt und glücklosen eines
glaube ich nicht dass das jetzt passiert
es mir fast nur mehr beschäftigt ist
dass es auch so viel die story geht
bezüglich der technik gibt wenig
positive technik entwirft und das recht
vor anderen wir zugelegt und dem
zusammenhang ist mir nochmals gespräche
mit allen penny in die feministin wo ihr
seid das eigentlich science fiction für
sie die große utopie maschinen ist wo
man eben wieder positiv über technik
danke jungs zeigt wichtig dass man die
sachen versucht positive bilder aus
danke was mit der technik nahles könnte
sich positive utopie wo man technik
zugeschrieben ist verschmerzen wo mensch
und maschine und hoffe nicht dass man
irgendeine schwirrt können
unsterblich sie und das ist böse aus t
maxi mit dem judoka radio parametern
jonas lüscher merlot sein was die zwei
dazu sagen
sie sagen der tod wird in zukunft mit
dieser partei ist ischen revolution mit
der revolution zum homo dem skin ein
technisches problem werden
und das ist ja auch etwas was viele
touristen sagen ray kurzweil ist ein
berühmtes beispiel dafür
zusammen mit einem google suchen
unternehmen sind sie daran den tod
abzuschaffen sie sagen bereits 2050
werden die regelmäßig hingehen
einen biologischen reset button drücken
können uns generalüberholen lassen und
dann können wir locker 400 jahre alt
werden glauben sie das wirklich
ich denke dass es noch verfrüht
im jahr 2050 werden wir noch nicht die
nötige technologie haben um das leben
unendlich fortsetzen zu können
doch in ein oder zwei 100 jahren könnte
es durchaus möglich sein
ich denke es kommen auch viele probleme
auf uns zu wenn wir das leben beliebig
verlängern können
zuerst einmal wird es wahrscheinlich
sehr teuer sein
zumindest für die ersten generationen
also haben nur die reichen die chance
jahrhundertelang schön und jung zu
bleiben
das wird gewaltige wut auslösen in der
armen bevölkerung
denn während die bisherigen
menschheitsgeschichte war ihr tod die
große ausgleichende macht die armen
konnten sagen die reichen haben zwar ein
gutes leben aber sie müssen wie wir
sterben
doch stellen sie sich eine welt vor in
der nur die armen sterben und die
reichen weiterleben
das wird viele wütend machen und wer
reich ist hat viel mehr angst als zuvor
denn wir reden hier nicht von
unsterblichkeit
sie können immer noch sterben sie haben
die möglichkeit unendlich zu leben dank
neuer behandlungen aber wenn sie zb von
einem auto überfahren werden sind sie
tot das kann niemand rückgängig machen
die angst vor dem tod wird also größer
sein denn je die menschen werden keine
risiken eingehen wollen
es war heute riskant hierher zu reisen
das flugzeug hätte abstürzen können doch
da ich so oder so sterben werde bin ich
bereit gewisse risiken einzugehen
aber da viele die chance ewig zu leben
nicht verpassen wollen weil sie diesen
oder jenen fehler machen gibt es wohl
nicht nur mehr wut sondern auch viel
mehr angst als je zuvor
ich glaube das nicht dass wir so weit
kommen werden dass unsere körper
unsterblich werden
da ist die biologie einfach nicht dazu
ausgerüstet selbst wenn wir noch so gut
dazu gucken und zell
erneuerungsmaßnahmen und weiß der teufel
was ich glaube ihre unsterblichkeit wird
er irgendwann eine möglichkeit sein im
sinne dessen dass wir erinnerungen und
das selbst so irgendwie auf eine
festplatte laden können und dann in neue
grippe oder auch maschinen weiter laufen
lassen dass er diese ganzen trans
humanistischen überlegungen von
verschmelzungen zwischen körper und
maschine haben die irgendwann eines
tages vermutlich realität werden wird
ich denke nicht zu unseren lebzeiten
wobei man weiß es und manchmal ist
verdammt schnell
und dann spielt natürlich dieses risiko
dann wieder gar keine rolle mehr so dann
ist man hier wirklich also gut dann muss
man angst davor haben dass irgendwie ist
man auseinandergeschraubt ja oder die
festplatte auf der man seine sicherheits
und wie gespeichert hat dass die
irgendwie runterfällt oder gehängt
ein virus erwischt so wirst du
eigentlich wer ewig aber wenn wir das
ding noch 180 mal muss man ja sagen dass
mit dem aber keine von der festplatte
zeigt ja dass der user die art von
sterblichkeit im kopf wo man sind sie
herne quasi und salat von chip und einem
neuen körper wieder läuft und das sind
die schulleitung so absolut wie es sogar
starke liebstem ihm auch das als wäre
ich nicht armin coerper ich einen
anderen körper nicht existieren sind sie
schon philosophisch gesehen relativ
bezahlbar es gibt ja noch die andere
vorstellung mit der biologischen und
sterblichkeit dass man den zelltod kann
die uhr schaute ehrlich gesagt ich jetzt
alles nicht groß fasziniert ich finde
der werk von moment ist gerade so
großartige immer schon weiß dass es an
die gold also begrenzt sich vom schöner
ist doch das was gutes macht das motiv
und carpe diem macht ja nur sinn die
analysten ihre manager rettig das
schönste moment vor dem landtag
ich werde sterben und darum hat sie
nein du musst doch nicht ganz die
dankenswerte starten aber das wissen
darum dass sachen endlich sind und dass
nicht alles in ewige repetition ich
finde ich eigentlich gut aber es ist
doch petition durch durchaus sich immer
wieder neu entworfen hatten wir schon
mal 300 400 500 jahre alt durchaus
verschieden aber durchaus top-model vera
spieler so viele andere thema wenn sie
mal wieder langlebigkeit 3 oder 3 oder 4
100 jahre heißt dann immer noch ein tod
nach 400 jahren als virtueller 400
worden
ich finde dass du eigentlich so eine
frage stellen lediglich einfach glaube
es gehört im moment zu mensch sie extrem
dazu dass man so eine spanne im korb
heizung 80 mitglieder 100 jahre und es
wird ganz neue modell bruch es wird zum
beispiel soll seriell ii lebenszeit
modellen gehe wahrscheinlich dass man
schlecht mehrere male ziemlich
hintergrund dass eine serielle partner
hat das mit brühe und das kajak
hoffentlich reizvoll im moment als ich
einfach nur du mich jetzt wahnsinnig
interessiert aber ich bin so also wenn
man neugierig ist natürlich was in
zukunft noch aus wird die letzte jahr
zurück was alles passiert ist finde ich
schön entspannen die vorstellig oder 32
die vorstellung noch viel länger
ich würde ich würds wären ja also ich
würde lieber das komme den entscheider
also das streamen von musik ich glaube
wenn man weiß man ist gefangen in einem
ewigen aber und thrombose ich habe das
ist irgendwo vor allem strom oder
empfindet und punkt vor bequem ich vor
dem höchsten berg immer noch glaubt
philosophie hat die standspur und im
auge die größere zahl slowake
zukunftssorgen und das chinesische frau
gestörtem einstellung aber du hast du
eine spezielle strategie antwort dass
man seit naja egal wie ecm hätte dann
immer noch möglichkeit vom selbstmord
von suizid
aber das ist ganz in andere foren
vertont will das wählt man sich in
bestimmten tag ich weiß nicht wieso aber
ich würde
wähle wisse aber einen tag ich sterbe
fängt das trio stellen
das gehört doch dazu hat das wir
überrascht wird vom tod oder dass man
nämlich gespült aber wenn du jetzt wirst
dich misst das datum ist genau klinik am
see januar zur musik und 87
kann ich das gut ich glaube müsse sich
daran gewöhnen also jetzt gehört haben
oder zur dass man noch nicht weiß aber
natürlich in zukunft so das festkleid
zudem kaum unternehmen noch starten
hatte oder das ist das radio aus dass
ich da ich brauche mal einen kaffee
[Musik]
der grieche angeschafft und natürlich
ist es vergnüglicher anregungen oder bio
im jahr 2010 sei eigentlich eine
schlussrate machen ring gepushte
untersagen biopic ein riesenthema
aber es ist sandig den wir so zurück wie
es mich fertiggemacht wurde ein gast
nach einem anderen irgendwie vor
laufender kamera zeit übrigens vergangen
oder ich schieße mit sicherheit kann
sich also maschine war dixie für
vegetarismus und wenn es ums überleben
geht dann ist das töten eines tieres aus
meiner sicht ein vernünftiger grund dann
sind wir uns allerdings einig dass in
unseren gesellschaften des nirgends
worum es überleben diesbezüglich mehr
geht also wir brauchen kein fleisch
nein das weiß jeder dass der mensch kein
fleisch braucht man kann lange darüber
streiten ob es wirklich gesund es sich
vegan zu ernähren da bin ich auch kein
experte aber vegetarier zu sein es
medizinisch unbedenklich ist es sogar
unterm strich gesünder
ich finde es wunderbar am leben zu sein
ich würde das leben eines anderen tieres
nicht beenden wollen
ich würde andere tiere auch nicht
grausam behandeln bloß weil ich sie
essen will
aus diesem grund esse ich kein tier
leben ist wertvoll
ich habe mich vor fünf jahren dazu
entschieden veganer zu werden
als experiment ich fühlte mich gesünder
also blieb ich dabei
für mich ist der tod von
nicht-menschlichen tieren moralisch
gesehen eine ernsthafte angelegenheit
darüber sollten wir gut nachdenken bevor
wir einen burger beißen denn es grenzt
an einen kannibalischen akt ich bin kein
vegetarier aber ich agiere nahe an der
grenze zum kannibalismus
das bringt mich in einen anstrengenden
moralischen rechtfertigungsdruck
man muss schon ein sehr großes vergnügen
dabei empfinden um das töten unseres
evolutionären cousins zu rechtfertigen
wäre es nicht konsequent wenn sie welche
hunde leben würden ja sie haben gerade
gesagt ob es eigentlich konsequent und
ich würde sagen
eigentlich ist es konsequent aber ich
bin nicht konsequent ich bin ich
konsequent alles in der moral am ende
auch nicht darauf ankommt dass wir in
allen moralischen fragen unausgesetzt
konsequent sind
das kann nicht das ziel sein also am
ende müsste dann das ziel der ethik
darin bestehen dass jeder ein heiliger
wird ich akzeptiere das finde das
wunderbar wenn jemand veganer ist aber
ich kann den maßstab das ist im leben
darauf ankommt ein durch und durch guter
mensch zu sein dann kann ich nicht dahin
ja und ziemlich darauf ab dass man durch
und durch guter mensch ist
ich rechnete ganz sieht und alles 000
brillen aber natürlich ganz anders ich
habe das problem mit dem ich eben
irgendwie sagen mich irritiert dass ich
in letzter zeit so viel zu tun dass er
moral und kurze touren besonders trias
problem also quasi ich kann dem
tennisspielen ich am rhein us ich kann
immer größer wenn die annoncen
moralischer mensch sehen war gerade im
bereich kochen
ich sehe das überhaupt muss stimmen sehr
fein kochen und trotzdem auf moralisch
fleisch essen ökologische bilanz so
schlecht ist und das theoretische gründe
und meint dass wir wieder geschafft und
hinten philosophische animationsfilm
hergestellt in der reihe viel los es
genau zu dem thema
[Musik]
stell dir vor du wirst aus dem schlaf
glas
[Applaus]
heerscharen von aliens überfallen
unserem planeten
[Applaus]
sie sind uns körperlich geistig und
technologisch weit überlegen
wir müssen für sie schuften und sie
nutzen uns für medizinische versuche
manche von uns lügen sie auch um mit
ihnen herum zu teilen und zu knuddeln
aber nicht alle menschen haben das glück
das haustier eines aliens zu sein
sie verspeisen uns menschen genüsslich
am liebsten zartes kinder fleisch
[Musik]
den frauen pumpen sie die milch ab und
machen daraus leckere drinks millionen
von menschen werden eingesperrt und
gemästet und anschließend geschlachtet
[Applaus]
völlig empört rennst du zum anführer und
stellt ihn zur rede
so kann es doch nicht weitergehen
wie könnt ihr nur so grausam sein was
regst du dich so aus nach dir denn nicht
dasselbe mit ihren lehrern
du verlierst den boden unter den füßen
hat er außerirdische nicht recht
verhalten wir uns tieren gegenüber nicht
genau so dürfen wir tieren etwas antun
was man uns nicht antun darf ja es ist
verstörend aber ich glaube es ist
wichtig dass man den perspektivwechsel
mal macht und das ist wieder moral hat
bisher sehr wichtig und ich glaube es
hätte ihnen grünen und also nehme ich am
schluss sagen was ist eigentlich warum
tiere bis auto was menschen etwas warum
sind die so verschieden
ich habe diesen dicken hier weniger klug
oder ein selber krass moralisches
empfinden aber es gibt viele menschen wo
das ohnehin ziemlich bezüglich oder der
pro sehr stark dement ist und die
behandlung war und ich finde dass es
sehr gut meint zumindest wie hast du mit
dem fleisch es seien ja eigentlich esse
kein fleisch aber wie und wo auch ihr
name ist 10 findet gebracht
auf dem stark für stück wieder zu und
anderen ist das fleisch kochen oder mit
ihnen kamen fleisch ist aber insgesamt
logisch so extrem auf das du ich hatte
gar keine chance jetzt ist er wieder da
ist aber immer noch eigentlich rational
strafe seiner inneren konflikt aber ich
find's einfach sehr verein und b
inkonsequent dem thema so vor oder
zurück zu meinen schultern aber geradezu
nicht eine viel größere zahl unserer
super lecker monster die ganze
kulturtechniken straße in zwei wochen
aber ruft ein anderer sieht jetzt die
moralische verfall hätten sich organ und
bezüglich einen klimawandel beschäftigt
und wir sind zum ersten stammtisch nach
basel ist lokal gut und hat extra
diskutiert ob man über hunderte flüge in
den letzten wochen und monaten konnte
man ja kaum eine zeitung aufschlagen
ohne dass einem das klima des
klimawandels entgegen
und meistens auch verbunden mit der
frage was ist eigentlich mit dem
vermehrten flugaufkommen die taten
wahrheit haben sich die flüge in den
nächsten 20 jahren verdoppelt weltweit
gesehen und welche verantwortung haben
eigentlich genau sie und ich angesichts
des klimawandels ist es denn wirklich
ein problem also ist fliegen ein thema
der moral sag ich jetzt mal drei
zentimeter es ist ganz vieles ein thema
der moralische und letztlich moral hat
ja auch damit zu tun was ich mache ich
muss wissen was ich tun wenn ich weiß wo
die möglichen schäden sind dann kann ich
mich so verhalten
aber dann müsste ich sagen okay fliegen
ist moralische fleisch essen ist unser
ist unmoralisch fleisch essen ist
unmoralisch wenn ich mich überhaupt zu
viel bewegung ist unmoralisch wenn ich
atme ist unmoralisch wenn wir quasi bei
diesen luftverschmutzung thema sind und
so weiter und so fort am schluss muss
ich sagen der mensch ist unmoralisch
eigentlich die tatsache dass wir da sind
schon unmoralisch und damit sind wir
gehen wir schon recht weit und glaube
ich dann ist er dann anfang ins detail
zu gehen
und was das moralische angeht kann man
ja sagen sollen auf einer abstrakten
ebene sind wir jetzt alle ganz moralisch
betroffen dass wir uns falsch verhalten
im rahmen der wirtschafts form in der
wir existieren verhalten wir uns ja hoch
moralisch wir sollen ja immer mehr
kaufen wir wollen immer mehr reisen wir
sollen immer mehr irgendwelche dinge
nehmen und wegschmeißen und so weiter
das heißt die moral diskussion ist er
schon mal völlig abstrahiert von dem was
eigentlich erforderlich ist damit der
laden funktioniert und dass das problem
und wir haben eben seit 200 jahren
mobilität kritisiert auf allen ebenen
und er das wirklich so fisch diskutieren
wollte und nicht um prozentzahlen
streiten will oder um technologische
mögliche möglichkeiten das ein bisschen
zu reduzieren treibstoff ausstoß ein
bisschen zu reduzieren durch bessere
motoren oder e mobilität für flugzeuge
irgendjemand wird auch auf diese idee
kommen einmal das nicht auf der kindisch
neben diskutieren wollen müssen wir
überhaupt einmal hinterfragen dieses
mobilitätskonzept ja es steht ja auch
nirgendwo geschrieben dass sich kreuz
und können
zu bewegen an sich und wert sein soll
man kann ja genau so die these vertreten
es wäre besser gerade doch in dem sinne
der philosophie die leute wie in sowie
kant in königsberg bleiben hogan und mal
ordentlich nachdenken dann kommen solche
warum blieben ordentlich noch danke
danke sich mann ist unbequem ist neu
aber die menschlichkeit mobilität
geschaffen
günstig ist unglaublich attraktiv und
sich zum teil fiel die schweizer jetzt
machen wir irgendwo im südlichen land
züge aber gleichzeitig finden muss
aufpassen heimreise mit tragischer
verkehrsmittel oder um 80 fraglichen und
ein das meer heißt dass man die neugier
nach gott andere ist auch der letzte
finde ich natürlich bis extrem schön
sein wenn ich überlege was hat mich im
leben gefragt denn dazu sicher alles bei
reisen wobei die große reise die mache
ich wirklich sehr wohl dosiert ich kann
ich einer hand abzählen und den
reisepreis hier langsam und leise mit
lokalen verkehrsmittel
ja ich mache also wenn eine große reise
machen versuche länger dass björk sie
ecuador und kolumbien zum beispiel jetzt
sind wir ihm gesagt über wochen wo sie
ab und zu flüge
beruflich das ist wirklich versucht
irgendwie ich finde die dosis macht's
und überlege stelle und traf mich wie
viel darf ich lüge und versucht es vor
allgemeiner wenn also alle menschen so
viele wirte bürger wird seine überhaupt
funktioniert das altbekannte regler von
der universität konnte ich versuche so
zu machen wo das problem natürlich ist
das ökologische fahrprogramme gigantisch
viel größeres wieder andere menschen
allein aufgrund der tatsache wie viel
wohnraum gebraucht wie mehrheits etwas
entlastet also ganze ist natürlich
wirklich nicht rechtfertigen soll
leistungsstärker werden die fragen schon
zurich film festival und das eigentlich
überraschende sehr optimistisch die welt
befindet sich gerade im frühen stadium
einer globalen nachhaltigkeitsrevolution
ermöglicht durch digitale werkzeuge wie
die künstliche intelligenz das internet
der dinge
sie hat den umfang der industriellen
revolution aber mit der geschwindigkeit
der digitalen revolution
sie ist eine realität in unserem leben
und wir sollten sie als basis für echte
hoffnung wahrnehmen
wir können das lösen wir werden es lösen
die entscheidende frage ist wie schnell
wir sie lösen werden und dass wir darauf
vertrauen können den point of no return
nicht zu überschreiten
also ich hab ganz viel aber bis jetzt
nicht geschafft mit ihrem wirklich
wahnsinnig man gerade jetzt der ganze
debatte um journalismus feminismus
braucht von sexismus und den gast und
ich eigentlich
ich finde den möbel roller machen hilft
der harry frankfurt eine ganz große
philosophen und 20 stellen mit 21
jahrhundert unter anderem ein bullshit
geschrieben und ich alle geblockt erich
dieser hub passieren dass wir risiken
und bei der begriffe passt ist zerstoben
im letzten januar und hätten zum thema
angst eigentlich alles wohl weg sein
ja ich hatte auch noch ein
südkoreanischer philosoph der jugend
schon reif ist für mich so ein fazit
diagnostik das wohl größte ist auch sehr
gut auf den punkt bringt zum beispiel da
die art vorschuss bekommt oft beträgt
wird derzeitigen historische chance
bietet und wird machen wir das
leidenschaftlich freiwillig und das
finde ich spannend ist
oder natürlich solid wieder probieren
die man unbedingt mal ist es ein ding
ist es sicher chancenlos aber mit
probiert es mal probiert und die große
kapitalismus-kritiker interhome genau
wie super ist und werden oft wenig
frauen ziemlich wahnsinnig langen
geraden dank der daniel barenboim hat
roland probiert bis dahin denn möglich
wurde kamera kann aber es lohnt sich
genau wäre auch nicht wo im moment ist
panisch accounts wo die wichtigste
stimme ist wenn es um rassismus gott in
den usa aber weiter ganz ganz große us
amerikanische intellektuelle wo mich
wahnsinnig interessiert und einen
totalen traum gast für mich die woody
allen ich bin großer woody allen film
einfach hoch philosophisch und wunderbar
luftig und komisch dass ein großer druck
auf uns war natürlich mit suiten mit dem
management in kontakt die mal das auch
so aber es heißt immer wieder zieht
wahrscheinlich sind und wie man es hätte
mir den griff glück der johnson franzen
zum beispiel wer gerne rumpsteak sich
aber es hätte wirklich nicht lang vom
zeitplan her
wir kriegen auf telefon und übrigens
wenn sie die heimatfreunde die es
wirklich immer über ivi ist über ideen
für ihre siebte speziell an philosophie
at / punkt ch oder via facebook und den
prüfen wir gern edel vorschläge wir
haben nach so liese glücks mitte eine
kluge liebte so lange straße stunden am
tag x die hintergrund diskutieren und
deshalb ist der heutige zieht im rahmen
wird er stichwort schnelle medien
soziale medien fake news
verschwörungstheorie und so wiederum
zudem zu den themen er seinen weg
gemacht und der gitarrist malawi text
eigentlich das definiert fake news und
verschwörungstheorien versuchen wir
nochmal einzugrenzen was fehlt - und
wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel tage die
sternstunde philosophie sind das
weltweit populärste philosophie format
dann ist das vielleicht richtig oder
falsch ich weiß es gar nicht ist das
schon fake news sind flunkereien oder
scherzhafte übertreibung fake news oder
gibt es da eine definitorischen
bestimmung die sagen das macht nix zu
finden ist wir haben soeben ein buch
über fake news geschrieben
in diesem buch klassifizieren wir
verschiedene aussagen ob sie als fake
news gelten oder nicht zuoberst in der
scala zum ersten bereich gehören setzte
die klare fakten ausdrücken
hier ist ein glas wasser sie tragen eine
brille und so weiter
das sind die geprüften fakten und gleich
eine stufe weiter unten gibt es
fabrizierte fakten aber wenn sie wollen
manipulierte aussagen
sie sind nicht unter den falsch sie
könnten zugeschnitten sagen was ist
ihnen lieber 90% beschäftigungen oder
zehn prozent arbeitslosigkeit unter dem
strich ist es das gleiche es geht über
selektionen wie man die dinge
präsentiert selektion wie man etwas
präsentiert rosinenpicken oder gewisse
fakten unterschlagen usw an dritter
stelle kommt das gerücht gerüchte können
wahr oder falsch seien
dann haben sie das was herr in frankfurt
gold nennt etwas das absichtlich keinen
unterschied zwischen wahrheit und
unwahrheit macht dann geht es lügen die
grundsätzlich falsch sind und
schließlich haben sie fällt - als
letzten punkt
die fake news sind in der regel an
milchprodukt das aber als echte aktuelle
news geschichte präsentiert wird das
macht sie speziell gefährlich nicht weil
zwangsläufig alles falsch ist sondern
weil es sich dabei um eine vorgespielte
realität handelt sie kommen als ersatz
realität daher
dadurch sind sie viel schwieriger zu
entlarven weil die gängigen kriterien
zur entlassung von behauptungen ganz
anders sind auch aus philosophischer
sicht ist das wirklich gift parasitäre
systeme die eigentlich aufsetzen auf
waren nachrichten und sich so geben
verkleiden und dann eine misch zone
gründen eine lebende chemtrails die dass
kondensstreifen dass flugzeuge cammy
verbreiten die klimalüge usw
ja wir müssen erklären was überhaupt
eine verschwörungstheorie ist gibt es so
etwas wie eine akzeptable definition
also ja in der forschung gibt es
eigentlich einen konsens eine
verschwörungstheorie ist eine theorie
die erklärt dass ein historisches
ereignis
sozusagen von einer kleinen gruppe von
eingeweihten im geheim durchgeführt
wurde und sozusagen eine andere version
offiziell verbreitet wird das heißt
verschwörungstheorien sind eigentlich
meistens theorien der macht und zwar
einer geheimen macht strippenzieher die
im geheimen agieren und die sozusagen
dann eine eine coverstory darüber
breiten und verschwörungstheorien haben
immer und das ist eigentlich auch ganz
interessant die tendenz sozusagen
offizielle wahrheiten zu hinterfragen
und auf diese diese dieses komplott
durchgreifen zu wollen
man könnte sagen macht und wissen dass
wissen wir dann unterdrückt es gibt ein
geheimnis
ich würde sagen verschwörungstheorien
neben diesen inhaltlichen definitionen
sind auch ein denkspiel oder eine
bestimmte psychische haltung und gegen
die rutschen wir ist an mir selber
gezeigt habe relativ leicht rein dann
ist plötzlich alles klar
und es ist faszinierend es ist nicht
diese blöde gewöhnliche geschichte in
der wir sind sondern es wird aufregend
ist irgendwie komisch schwierigsten eine
kosmische armut sind die stop schild
bild wie ihr vater und ich gerade
immanuel kant mit dem begriff der
rasenden und wo eigentlich zu wort wo
alles wird der klare wahrscheinlich für
mich zu suchen in den decken jahr 2007
zeit dass die komplexe welt nicht nur
verlangt auf vernunft appellieren
sondern auch mitunter einheitlichen
umgang und angeschafft bescheide sie und
über das post faktische die totale
institute in rüschlikon diskutiert mit
dem ilja trojanow unter lorin dachten
ich habe schon gesagt man sagt die
wahrheit stecke in einer krise wie sieht
denn diese krise auch wenn sie darauf
blicken
zuerst für sich sorgen es ist keine
krise der wahrheit keine krise der
fakten die wahrheiten die fakten sind
was sie immer waren es ist eine krise
von wissen und die quellen von wissen es
ist auch eine krise von vertrauen wem
dürfen wir vertrauen und eine krise auch
vielleicht von medienbildung wie gehen
wir mit den neuen medien um glaube es
ist an der zeit diese stimmen hier auch
anzuhören
deswegen gebe ich gerne ihnen das wort
stellen sie gerne ihre fragen was also
mich würde interessieren sie beide wie
optimistisch sind sie denn jetzt gerade
bezug auf solche fake news auf solche
gegen wahrheiten also erfundene gegen
verhalten bei denen ein unglaublich
großer einerseits anreiz da ist auch ein
unglaublicher macht und geld geld
dahinter steht kapital dahinter steht
das zu steuern und gleichzeitig auch die
technischen möglichkeiten sie haben es
erwähnt mit mit facebook
weltumspannend ist dass man trotz dieser
vielen herausforderungen optimistisch
bleiben kann und sagt wir wir lösen
dieses problem auf welche weise auch
immer
ja also ich bin insofern optimistisch
weil ich glaube dass und der
gesellschaft in der ich leben wird
nämlich an der wirklich in jeder
hinsicht durch und durch demokratische
freiheitliche gesellschaft sich das
problem weniger stellt also ich glaube
dass das tram problem im moment der form
darin besteht dass er überhaupt kein
interesse daran hat ob irgendeine
aussage wahr ist oder nicht
er hat ja mehr mehrmals völlige lügen
zitiert als man ihn konfrontiert hat mit
der tatsache dass sie falsch sind alle
gesagt na ja ich habe es im internet
gelesen wer bin ich zu überprüfen ob
stimmt und das ist ja sozusagen das
zentrale dass er und ich nenne jetzt nur
repräsentativ für eine entwicklung
überhaupt nicht sich die wahrheit frage
gestellt und das ist ja leninistischer
also es dient jetzt einen bestimmten
zweck
ergo kann ich das in die welt
hinausposaunen da sehe ich tatsächlich
eher eine machtfrage anhangs gemacht und
ich glaube es gibt gar kein hang es geht
zusammenhang zwischen macht und meinige
werden einfach die mächtige meinen
körper floss aber trabis ganz anders
wort ist sozusagen ganz traditionell
wurde das theorie sei die ware die
stimmung ist einmalig oder vorstellungen
mit der realität wie sie wirklich und
die realität kann man nicht verändere
mich als sozusagen einige der anderen
verliert das klappt realität nicht gibt
es denn die realität
ich glaube die geht's wir können nicht
erkennen
darum würde ich mich selber die
skeptiker bezeichnet
aber es ist ein wichtiger punkt nämlich
auch sagen was nützt diesen worten wir
waren dran aber was will die jeder
zugang zur wirklichkeit läuft über diese
vorstellung über böse geister eigentlich
oder mich und eigentlich hier wie sie
vorstellungen mit dem wirklich erwartete
hinter friedlichere welt
jeder zugegangen ist schon mental das
ist das problem
was ist zwischen zwei mal gemacht und
und wort also warten fordert wirklich
schön wie du was ich im moment
interessanter in die scheide zusammen
zuschauer macht und will seinerseits
eigentlich gehts zur demokratisierung
vom müsse mit der ganzen digitalisierung
also hätte dass wikipedia informationen
und wissen ist eigentlich frei
zugänglich und das merkt man jetzt
stimmt aber nur das frucht einer sitz
bild man muss keine mit der
informationsflut angaben muss keine
lehre unterscheiden und für das braucht
natürlich einen stand sowohl die
unterscheidungen für alles machen sagt
roller von den medien ist natürlich eine
wo immer wichtiger wird oder wollen muss
diskutieren und musste was dir heißt
denn im digitalen zeitalter um das buch
medienkompetenz vor der leserinnen und
leser dass man der schule wie bringen
die 40 lang alle roxy und ich habe
gemerkt irgendwie ein bisschen müsse
recherchieren im internet oder irgend
welche medien zitieren und sowas ist so
schwierig oder und das muss man nicht
mehr mit der flutung der komplexität
können uns glauben die selbe programm
algorithmus aus verträgen wie möglich an
dieses jahres meistern oder mehr innere
parallel arbeiteten landete ein andere
schreibung ich meine scham beschäftigt
ist dass ich mehr mitglied ein oder
treten sagte ich widme mich interessiert
an information nicht wirklich ich finde
es gar nicht so wichtig wie die wartet
das passierte schlug ministerien oder
instagram unterwegs und erfahren was für
mich wichtig ist und da bin ich wie man
sich natürlich bedeutet informiert sie
auch macht insofern dass nach angriffen
und sogar innere direkter demokratie
haben sie nicht stimmen haben und sich
wehren ferrari setzte also
sprichwörtlich würden
innere demokratie ich glaube aber dass
das schon früher aktiv das einfach
größte lücke hat wohl nicht interessiert
sind und ich glaube sie mich war die
gratiszeitungen und wieder hat willi
tätige wofür die 100 hz die klasse hat
120 minuten nicht und so hat nicht so
viel fixiert oder das blick aber ich bin
mir gar nicht so sicher ob es bergab
geht in sachen informationsstand
[Musik]
unglaublich
uwe herzel im ausland ist es sehr
stücken einsame stern studie
vorschlagen ja ja ich nehme täglich
vorsatz weniger in der zukunft sondern
mit der geburt weniger vorsatz macht und
du bist doch ein großer moment ist das
ist was eine religion und eben noch
nicht weg kann organ vorsatz klartext
würde sich die idee von peter sloterdijk
sehr gut mit der radikal sparen ich die
idee dass man sagte uns rechnet und über
sich selber oder machst und irgendwie
immer noch bis heute das spiel und hätte
böse sehen dass es auch geist und wenn
man sagt eingereicht sondern einfach
dass man so eigentlich jungen repariert
das reicht aber schön aber ich muss mich
klingt so an einem die familie nicht nur
zur klasse vorsatz ich möchte ja sondern
lange druck burgen und dank passen wir
das einfach mit dem mit dem moment
sowieso das in der oft gefühl nicht
klappt funktioniert habe ich von meiner
tag wenn ich sage wir haben nicht
erlaubt haben impress 17 und direkt in
der herberge wenn man mit tierisches
glücklichste als erfüllt das irgendwie
regeln und schlüssel so einfach
das ist schwieriger umzusetzen was
eingriffe hat glücklich und des glücks
das macht das team aber so ein
philosophischer evergreen ist und hätte
als ein dicker 2010 bezahlt so große
rolle gespielt und immer wieder von
neuem
für mich ist das größte glück in meinem
leben wenn ich eine aufgabe habe die all
meine fähigkeiten in anspruch nimmt
all meine stärken meine ganze
konzentration das gelungene leben ist
für mich ein leben in dem wir selbst
bestimmt unsere projekte leben die
sinnvoll sind und in dem wir dazu
dennoch glücklich sind
es ist ein großartiges gefühl wenn sie
ein neues phänomen entdeckt haben und
sie ist als erster mensch sehen
das ist schon etwas besonderes die
zufriedenheit im leben ist bei vielen
menschen eine kurve das heißt in dir mal
dass sie wahrscheinlich gerade hier ist
aber es wird besser
das nennt sich sozusagen diese der
tiefpunkt ist die rushhour des lebens
sie sind gerade bei karriere zu machen
sie haben eine junge familie
sie haben 1000 dinge an die an
dienstherren und da ist man vorher
freier und danach auch wieder unglück
ist immer ein kurzes glück
man muss geht der blick etwas anfang ist
im großen ganzen etwas was ich
herbeisehne wenn ich es nicht haben wenn
ich ganz bei der sache bin dann bin ich
ein mensch der nicht mehr nach dem glück
fragt was heißt glück erlebt man nie
sondern man vermisst es ja richtig also
das glück findet in jeder faser um so
das dasein statt wenn wir uns nicht mehr
fragen sind wir glücklich oder nicht das
passende leben ist das auch das
sinnvolle leben ja weil wir mit allen
fonds und danach streben aber man sollte
das nicht das ziel ansehen sondern
ausweg wenn ein angriff gehen sie mal
skaliert nachher töten sie länger so
kommt hat er wie so berührt mich den und
ich bin dann so haas' wirklich durch
glückshormone durch strömt das mein
gehirn nur noch mit 0 super wir haben
die damen und herren sind schon an die
vor ihrem jahresrückblick und auch noch
erwartet ist wieder interessant die
sprüche und sandige unter anderem bin
ich im januar an bürger im webforum
umfrage die mehrheit eigentlich gemacht
der digital rad und barbara ist in
irland unterwegs
[Musik]
mit dem break südstadt natürlich irland
wieder neue serie unterscheiden von den
gründen warum ich auf die insel gereist
und natürlich interessiere mich freuen
die philosophische frage wo nicht auch
eine diskutieren unter anderem zum
beispiel wenn gehört eigentlich das land
und dafür benötigen wir einfach sagen
mehreren unabhängigkeit und natürlich
weiter in irland auch über serie game of
thrones und könnte man dieser hype nach
weitere fernsehserie wo ja ganze 3 j als
auch in irland befindet
jörg stuke kurz und macht vor der spruch
ich heute mit dem philosoph übel und
jetzt grad zeigt mir dass viele
künstlerin käthe kollwitz ja und jetzt
wünschen wir ihnen allen einen guten
rutsch und das kurz 2008 und als auch
gar nicht so
[Musik]